When we first started talking
about central tendencies and
how we measure average, we
talked about the arithmetic
mean and there you just added
up the numbers and you
divided by the number
of numbers there were.
So let's say our population
of numbers is-- we have a 3.
Let's say we have three
3's, a 4, and a 5.
That's our population.
And if we wanted the population
mean here we were just
add all the numbers up.
We'd say 3 plus 3 plus
3 plus 4 plus 5.
And then we would divide
that sum by the number
of numbers we have.
We would divide that by 5.
And we would come--let's see.
What would this be?
This would be 9 plus
9; it'd be 18/5.
That would be 18/5,
which would be what?
3 and 3/5, which is 3.6.
It's a population mean for
this population of numbers.
If we just rearranged the math
here a little bit we could view
it a slightly different way.
How many 3's do we have?
We have three 3's, so we could
view this as 3 times 3.
How many 4's do we have?
We have one 4, so
it's plus 1 times 4.
Plus 1 time 5.
All of that divided by 5.
And then what we could do
is, this is the same thing.
And I'm just doing a little
bit of basic really,
number manipulation here.
This is the same thing as
1/5 times 3 times 3 plus
1 times 4 plus 1 times 5.
And if we distribute this
1/5 this is equal to what?
3/5 times 3 plus 1/5 times 1.
So it's plus 1/5 times
4 plus 1/5 times 5.
And this we can see in a
bunch of different ways.
Let me express
these as decimals.
So 3/5.
So it's 0.6 times 3 plus 0.2
times 4 plus 0.2 times 5.
Or we could express these
decimals as percentage.
We could say 60% times 3, plus
20%-- sorry, 20% times 4.
Plus 20% times 5.
This is identical to adding up
the numbers and then dividing
by the total number of
numbers there are.
But this is interesting because
here we had to know how many
total numbers there are.
We have to say, OK, we added up
5 numbers, we divided by 5.
All I did is I played
around with the
arithmetic a little bit.
And I got to this expression.
But this expression's more
interesting, or at least
it's-- well, it's different.
It's not necessarily
more interesting.
I don't want to make any
value judgment about it.
But here I don't know how
many numbers there are.
I'm just telling you about the
frequency of the numbers.
I'm telling you that 60% of
the numbers are 3, 20% of
the numbers are 4, and then
20% of the numbers are 5.
And then if I were to calculate
this out I would get
60% times 3 is 1.8.
Plus 20% times 4 is 0.8.
Plus 20% times 5
is-- let's see.
20% plus 1, which would
be equal to 2.6, plus
1 is equal to 3.6.
So we would get the exact same
number, but what's interesting
here is that this tells you
just the frequencies-- really
the relative frequencies of the
3's, the 4's, and the 5's.
What percentage of this
population is 3's?
60%.
What percentage is 4's?
20%.
And what population is 5's?
And I'm doing that because we
just talked about random
variables and all of that.
In the beginning we started our
statistics discussion about
populations and samples.
But if you think about it,
every time you do one of your
experiments and you get a new
value for a random variable--
let's do our classic example.
We have our random variable, x,
is equal to-- I don't know--
it's equal to the number of
heads after 6 tosses
of a fair coin.
So that's our random variable.
Hopefully now, we can kind of
connect what we thought about
in terms of just arithmetic
mean and central tendency and
population versus sample, and
then connect that to the
notion of a random variable.
So when we first started
talking about statistics we
said, OK, you have this
notion of a population.
And that you would
sample the population.
And we gave a couple
of examples.
You know, the most common one
is you wanted up predict
the outcome of a
presidential election.
The population is everyone
who's going to vote
in the election.
You can't survey all 50 million
people or whatever's going
to vote for the election.
So what you do is you survey
a random sample of that
population and then you can
calculate statistics on that
sample that hopefully can
estimate the population
as a whole.
But what happens if the
population is not finite?
And just to go back, if the
population is finite you can
calculate things like
the population mean.
We learned the population
mean was that mu letter.
And that was you just literally
take up all of the items in the
population, add them together,
and you divide by the
number of items there are.
That's what we did up here.
If this was a whole population
of numbers, we've figured
out that this was mu.
If this was a sample from a
population then this would
be the sample mean, but we
learned all about that.
But that's not what I
want to get at now.
But what happens if this
population is infinite?
If it's infinite and you're
like, oh, Sal, that
doesn't make any sense.
But if you think about it,
well, a random variable really
is-- you can kind of view it as
each instance of a
random variable.
Or every time you performed
the experiment you're taking
out an instance of an
infinite population.
You can perform this experiment
an infinite number of times.
You can just keep doing it.
It's not like, after doing it a
thousand times you're like, oh,
you can't toss a coin six times
anymore and count the
number of heads.
You can perform
this indefinitely.
So every specific result from a
random variable-- and those are
usually lowercase results,
lowercase x1 or x2 or x3.
These are just specific
instances of a random variable.
You can view these as samples
from an infinite population.
So I'll try to draw an
infinite population;
it's kind of harder.
Maybe I'll draw arrows that
go off in every direction.
This population never ends.
You can keep performing the
experiment and keep getting
samples, but you're sample
is usually finite.
You know, let's say we
performed this experiment.
We toss a fair coin six times
and we do that experiment--
I don't know-- we do
it a hundred times.
So then we would have a hundred
samples, x2 and it would
go all the way to x100.
And the reason why I'm doing
this connection is one, to make
you see the connection between
the random variable and the
probability, and the statistics
that we talked about earlier.
And in this video, I'm going to
introduce you to the concept of
the expected value of
a random variable.
And it's nothing else.
So the expected value of a
random variable, the expected
value of a random variable is
the exact same thing as
the population mean.
In fact, sometimes it's
called a population mean.
But what makes it interesting
is in this situation, you
have an infinite population.
So you can't just add up all
the numbers and divide by the
number of numbers you have
because you have an infinite
number of numbers.
But what you can do is if
you said wow, I know the
frequency of the numbers.
I know that 3 shows up 60%
of the time, 4 shows up
20% of the time, 5 shows
up 20% of the time.
Then, even if you have an
infinite number of numbers,
you can actually still
calculate a mean.
And that's how you do it
for an expected value
of a random variable.
So how do you figure out
the frequencies that
numbers show up?
Well, you can look at the
probability distribution,
the discreet probability
distribution.
So in that example that we did
last time, I forgot the exact
numbers, but actually let
me just take what we
did-- our Excel out.
Let me just quickly, I want to
make n 6 trials, probability
of heads, tails-- OK, 0.5.
And then I need to change
what this chart-- just
give me one second.
Change what the inputs
of this chart are.
I'm off the screen right now.
OK, there you go.
So this is the probability
distribution for what
I just described.
I have a fair toss of a coin
and I want to know how many
heads I have after 6 tosses.
So you can perform this
experiment a bunch of times,
but this tells you the
frequency, the frequency
of that random variables.
So when you perform that
experiment-- let's see,
whatever this is--
0.09% of the time.
No, actually, 9% of the
time you're going to
get exactly 1 head.
23% of the time you're
going to get 2 heads.
31% of the time you're
going to get 3 heads.
23% of the time you're
going to get 4 heads.
And then, you know 9% of
the time you're going
to get 5 heads.
And then 2% of the time
you're going to get 6 heads.
So if you have that information
you can then actually figure
out the population mean for
this population that's
described by this probability
distribution, or the
expected value.
And let's do that right here.
I'll put this over to the side.
So I'm looking at that chart
I just did while I do this.
We just looked at the
probability distribution for
this random variable, the
number of heads after 6
tosses of a fair coin.
So the expected value of our
random variable is going
to be each outcome.
So the first outcome is that
we had 0 heads times the
frequency that 0 shows up.
So we figured out before that
the frequency-- now, it's a
little inexact because I don't
have-- actually, I have
the exact numbers.
0 will show up in our random
variable 0.01563% of the time.
So let me write that.
So we're going to say, well,
this happens and I can
write it as a percentage
1.563% of the time.
Plus 1 happens
9.375% of the time.
And then plus 2 happens
23.438% of the time.
Plus 3 happens-- let's see,
it says 31.25% of the time.
Almost there.
4, I get 4 heads out of 6
tosses 23% percent of the time.
So times 23.438%.
I get 5 heads after 6
tosses 9.375% of the time.
And finally, I get all heads
let's see-- no, I get all
heads 1.563% of the time.
And that makes sense again
because all heads should be
just as likely as all tails.
All tails is the same
thing is no heads.
So what we did here is
exactly what we did up here.
We took the relative frequency
of each of the numbers in the
population and we multiply that
outcome times its relative
frequency, and we're
adding it up.
But this is the exact same
thing mathematically
as we did up here.
But what's useful now is we can
apply the same principles, but
we're finding the arithmetic
mean of an infinite population,
or the expected value of a
random variable, which is the
same thing as the arithmetic
mean of the population of
this random variable.
So this value would be equal
to-- actually, let me just
use Excel to calculate it.
So the expected value of
getting-- the number of heads
you get after 6 tosses.
So this is 0 times its
frequency, and then I'm going
to add them all up and then
just will just do that
same thing in all of it.
So this says this will be 1
times its frequency, 2 times
its frequency, and then if I
were to take the sum of all of
them-- equals sum of all of
these-- I get exactly 3.
And that's actually kind of
an expected outcome, right?
I shouldn't use the word
expected too much.
That the central tendency or
you could say, the population
mean, of this random variable,
or you could say the expected
value of this random
variable is exactly 3.
And in this example it turned
out that 3 is also in kind of
the colloquial sense, it's
the most expected value.
It's the most probable value.
But we'll see in the future
that the expected value
doesn't have to be the
most probable value.
You could have a very high
probability of having no heads
and a very high probability
of having 6 heads.
And then you'd still have an
expected value of 3, even if
6 or 0 were more probable.
And I'll show you more
examples of that.
But the purpose of this video
is to really show you that the
expected value calculation
is the same thing as the
population mean calculation,
but we do it this way because
you can't add up an infinite
number of data points and
divide by an infinite number.
Instead you want to know the
frequencies of each of the
outcomes and then you just add
up all the outcomes weighted
by their frequencies.
But that's no different than
what you did up there.
And I really want to hit that
point home because sometimes in
probability books they'll just
give you a formula-- oh, the
expected value of a probability
distribution is each of the
outcomes times their frequency.
But I want to show you that
that is the same thing
as the population mean.
Anyway, see you in
the next video.